in a little while i'm just going to say
i'm very happy for you and the success
coming your way
oh thank you mate i appreciate that
frosty that's so lovely to say
uh if someone has actually never seen
anything that you've done before what is
the first thing you want them watching
and why
oh wow
that's that's a that's a difficult one
to nail down actually because it's
almost like asking you what what your
favorite project is and and i don't
actually have one um
you know but
if i if i'm gonna start i would i'd
probably
point people in the direction of lord of
the rings first i i think that that's uh
um
that's a that's a
pretty good place to start yeah when you
signed on to the boys which when i first
saw it you know i'm like oh this is a
really good show did you have any idea
that it was going to become what it's
become
i mean you never really know how
something's going to be received and uh
you know you certainly
you know you you hope that it finds an
audience because you you know you work
so
so long and hard on it and um you know
and and and um
you know when it does connect the way
that the boys have it has it's uh
it's um you know you just feel you know
a sense of relief that you you know in a
sense that uh you're happy for
everybody involved in the project
because you know i'm just a small sort
of cog in the machine but there's
from the writers to the crew to
other actors um so many people involved
in it so it's it's nice for everybody
that you know just to be
to know that audiences are having as
much fun you know watching it is that we
are and making it well you guys have
done some pretty outrageous things in
all three seasons do you have one that
stands out as are you effing kidding me
we're about to do this
yeah i mean i was i guess i mean listen
every time you you open up a script and
uh read something in the boys there you
every single episode you come across
that moment of are you serious so are
they going to actually do this um for me
personally i think slamming a speed boat
into a whale was
pretty outrageous uh you know
i mean you know one of the most
benevolent beautiful creatures on the
planet and we're just gonna ram a speed
boat into it but that's the wacky world
of the boys uh jumping into sea beast uh
i thought this movie is fantastic i
thought chris did such a great job with
it um what are you actually most excited
for audiences to see with the film uh
listen i'm most excited for audiences
just to see this film period uh it's i
think it's a rather special and unique
film i really think that the sea beast
really pushes the uh the the boundaries
of animation i've never seen anything as
textually rich uh in the world of
animation as the sea beast uh beyond
that i think that the the characters in
the story are um
are really endearing you know what i
responded to was
the story of this uh
this monster hunter who's sort of tough
brawny monster hunter called jacob
holland
uh who
you know
sort of comes into contact with this
young stowaway and through the course of
their adventures you know
comes to
rethink everything that he believes
about the world and uh to me that's a
pretty sort of interesting and
thought-provoking concept that you can
never be too stuck in your ways if you
get presented with new information that
that you should be open to the paradigm
shift i think that's pretty cool yeah it
also um uh it speaks to a lot of stuff
going on in our world today without
without intent you know with that aspect
of the film uh but what do you think
would surprise people to learn about the
like being the main character in an
animated movie and like what goes on
behind the scenes
uh well you know it's an interesting and
really challenging uh process to be a
part of unlike when you're working on
something like the boys where you have
all of the other actors that in the in
the scenes that you're with they're on
and you have
you know everything in front of you um
when you're working on an animated movie
you have nothing you you do not know
what the other actors sound like you do
not know
what the delivery of their lines are
and ostensibly you know you you're
working in a vacuum and you know i was
very um fortunate to be working with
chris williams our director on this and
he would read all the other characters
lines and he would describe the scene
and sometimes i would get like a
previews of of what the scene was which
which helped um
but for the most part it's you know a
huge sort of leap in in your imagination
to create that world and put yourself in
the moment and
and um then you're always amazingly sort
of surprised when you see the film and
and uh
and and see you know sort of the true
scope and scale of of what it is that
they've created what is it like when you
have to make those sounds of like
running or like that those weird sounds
to do you know what i mean not like the
doc
i got to confess i hate doing that all
the little grunts and groans
you know
and it feels really ridiculous when
you're in the booth and yeah and it's
like okay now we're going to do efforts
and he's like oh please you know you've
been in the sound booth for four hours
and then the last thing you do is like
half an hour of efforts um but uh
you know i'd rather i'd rather
it be organic and come from me than
somebody else do it one of the things
watching the finished film was i
couldn't believe the quality of the
animation and for people that don't
realize doing water effects in animation
is not easy and this movie is all water
and uh so i just want to know what was
it like actually seeing the finished
film for you because it's so beautiful
to look at yeah i mean i mean i think my
response would probably exactly the same
as yours i was completely unprepared and
blown away by the finished film
i think the sea beast really you know
pushes the boundaries of of animated
movies and it's textually so rich you
know there's the
the detail of the individual grains of
sand or as you said the sort of the
reflection and the way the light plays
off the water it's a beautiful film and
you know and it's got a lot of heart and
and uh it's just good epic family fun i
think there's something in it for
everybody for sure also it has a crazy
amount of action that's really well
choreographed and shot you know this
isn't uh it's i mean i i just can't say
enough about how great of a job chris
did yeah no he's brilliant and that's
you know really chris was uh
one of the most important elements that
drew me to the film i mean he was so
passionate about this movie he lived it
and breathed it it oozed it out of every
single pour and and
you know really this project was for me
a leap of faith with chris williams and
knowing that he was going to be able to
you know deliver something truly
extraordinary and and he really has he's
knocked it out of the park i can't wait
for audiences to see it before i run out
of time with you i actually want to do a
follow-up on the boys if you don't mind
um i noticed the facial hair is in full
effect
uh does this mean that you're going back
to start filming a certain new season
soon yeah we're starting uh i think
august the 22nd we're gonna be starting
uh season four so i'm
you know getting back getting my butcher
back on and uh i can't wait you know
it's uh
uh it's uh it's it's a fun game to play
with you know we um
uh we we work hard and play hard and and
uh i can't i can't wait to see where
they take the characters um from where
we leave them at the end of the season
yeah i've seen the whole season three
and uh i might i cannot wait for the
next season does eric tell you in
advance like how early does eric or
anyone involved in the production
actually tell you about what's coming in
the next season
well what are we now we're about two
months away from filming and i have no
idea so
that'll tell you something uh but
they're not too far away i mean i expect
that you know we'll i'm actually seeing
um crypt next week and i expect
conversations will will start to happen
about you know what he's got in store
and i i like to give them the uh
the respect of of being able to
do their writing process and and not be
harassed by actors going what are we
doing um but i can't wait you know they
always come up with uh
insane stuff so
yeah it's gonna be fun
listen man as i said before i i'm so
happy for your success and i wish you
nothing but the best thank you for your
time thanks man all right take care